guys what's up we are back on the road
again as the Impractical Jokers tore the
United States of America
impracticaljokerslive.com we're going to
be in Reading Pennsylvania Pittsburgh
Camden New Jersey Boston
Prudential Center in Newark and UBS
Arena Long Island just to name a few all
the tickets are on sale right now we're
touring through July and we're adding
more dates and practicaljokerslive.com
I'm going to every single one when on my
off time what I'm gonna do is I'm going
I'll be in Phoenix Arizona January 26 to
28th that's this Thursday to uh Saturday
at the stand up live christycomedy.com
for Ticky wikis February 1st and 2nd
Cleveland Ohio hilarities almost all the
shows are sold out but go see even get
tickets
um Stanford Connecticut February 16th to
17th and Vancouver February 22nd
February 24th Fresno February 25th San
Jose 26 Sacramento and then Florida on
there in March is christycomedy.com for
Ticky wikis just we're gonna Sal's gonna
do my shows I'm gonna do Sal shows it's
going to be a whole thing come to all
the shows
foreign
[Music]
still the same OG but I've been low-key
hate it on by most these hey babes with
no cheese no deals no G's no wheels no
keys No bows no snowmobiles no skis mad
at me because I can finally afford to
provide my family with groceries got a
crib with a studio when it's all full of
tracks the head for the wall full of
plaques hanging up in the office and
back of my house like trophies y'all
think I'm a go freeze hold please you've
been about down on both knees who you
think taught you to smoke trees who you
think brought you the oldies easy ease
ice cubes and docs the Snoop deal Double
G's and the group that said [__]
police gave you a tape full of dope
beats to bum when you stroll through in
the hood and when your album says one
dudes are good who's the doctor they
told you to go see y'all better listen
up closely or you haven't said that I
turned pop on the firm flop y'all the
reason that Dre Ain't can't get no sleep
so [__] y'all all of y'all if y'all
don't like me blow me y'all gonna keep
[__] around with me and turn me back
to the old me nowadays everybody want to
talk like they got something to say but
nothing comes out when they move the
lips just a bunch of gibberish and
[__] that they've got About Dre
nowadays everybody want to talk like
they got something to say but nothing
comes out when they move to live just to
put the gibberish and [__]
exactly forgot about trade so what do
you say to somebody you hate and he
wouldn't try to bring trouble your way
want to resolve things in a bloody way
just study a tape NWA one day I was
walking by with a Walkman on when I
called a guy give me an awkward eye
strangled him up in the parking lot what
it's called can I I don't give a [__] if
it's dark or not I'm harder than me
trying to park a Dodge when I'm drunk as
[__] right next to a humongous truck in
the two-car garage hopping out with two
broken legs trying to walk it off [__]
you too [__] call the cops imma kill
you when I'm not as [__]
barking dogs and when the cops came
through me and Dre stood next to a
burned down house with a can full of gas
and a handful of matches and still
weren't found out right here so from
here on out to Chronic two starting a
day tomorrow's the new and I'm still
local enough to choke you to death with
Charles and two tickets to the Mercedes
little twin babies in a Mercedes these
bands are the windows up when the temp
goes up to the mid 80s calling men
Ladies sorry doc but I've been crazy
there's no way that you can save me it's
okay go with him Haley
nowadays everybody want to talk like
they got something to say but nothing
comes out when they move to live it's
just a bunch of gibberish [__]
they've got About Dre nowadays everybody
want to talk like they got something to
say but nothing comes out when they move
to live just a bunch of gibberish
[__] actually Forgot About Dre
who was up to me you [__] would
stop coming up to me with your hands out
looking up to me like you want something
free when my last CD was out you wasn't
bumping me but now that I got this
little company everybody want to come to
me like it was some disease but you
won't get a Crump from me cause I'm from
the streets of Compton
I told them all are you little gangsters
who you think helped mold them all now
you want to run them out talk about guns
like I ain't got none what you think I
sold them all because I stay well off
now all day all day I hate the Dre fell
off why because I've been in the lab
with a pet in the pad trying to get the
same label off I ain't having that this
is the Millennium I've had the man they
ain't gonna be nothing after now there's
gonna be one more Platinum plaque [__]
around you could have it back so where's
all the Mad rappers at it's like a
jungle in his habitat but all you savage
cats know that I was trapped with guys
when you were cuddling the Cabbage Patch
nowadays everybody want to talk like
they got something to save nothing comes
out when they move the lips just about
to dibberish a [__] exactly
They Forgot About Dre nowadays everybody
want to talk like they got something to
say but nothing comes out when they move
to live it's just about gibberish and
[__] exactly Forgot About Dre
nowadays everybody wanna talk like they
got something to save nothing comes out
when they move their lives just a bunch
of gibberish and [__] act like
they've forgotten to me baby
I'm
I had one line
wow now I was saying that like eight
years I used to know it but it was it
was tough it was well now for those of
you listening too much on reading it Sal
just spit that straight off the Dome
piece
hey babe hey babe
buddy yeah I just want to clarify yeah
yes I just want to get out of the way
immediately all right I know you know
what people are thinking what you've
been thinking my hair is combed to the
other side today that I mean I was
really wondering what something looked
different I couldn't tell I literally
for literally years of my life my whole
life since I've had hair since I started
growing hair that's three months old I
thought I always pushed my hair that
away but I have a cowlick on my head
right here even my barber who's a great
Barber guy I can't figure out this damn
cow look on you I just have like most
people have a cowlick in the back I have
a cowlick my hair just Parts naturally
this way so I so yesterday I'm just kind
of frustrated I said I want to shave my
head I said I said to my one-year-old
daughter I said I'm gonna [__] shave
my head I want to look just like you all
right and she was just sitting there
drinking her milk and then Jasmine said
you know you're getting frustrated
getting upset she goes let me look at
you so she's looking at me she go I was
like the goddamn cowlick is on this side
and I can't figure it out and she was
like have you ever thought of combing
your hair the other way towards the
cowlick she said what do we always talk
about in therapy don't resist well
you've been you've been resisting and
combing your hair the other way instead
of just going towards
the garlic yeah you're not this way you
don't resist it you become it so what
you're seeing is I have just become the
cowlick how do you feel I feel like my
hair's too high
well because it's forcing your hair to
to fight and go the way I mean we are so
you have body and bounce like you've
never had in a while I've never had it
and I gotta be honest with you I don't
know how to deal with it it's a lot of
pressure it's a lot of power to have
this much body this much bounce yeah now
let me ask you a question your normal
hair goes to your right when you comb it
my normal hair yes usually if I comb it
it goes to the right so mine goes to the
left wow okay that's why we complete
each other we have a good part it is you
complete me and I've talked about this
and my barber says you should go again
it's always good to go the other way for
a while and then go back the other way
for a while it trains your hair to go
both ways it'll keep it high and he says
to me go this way to the right your way
and I do it in the mirror and I
literally feel like I I have a uh like a
like a tick like I do it and it's like
this is wrong yeah I can't I don't like
it that way I look in the mirror and I
feel like I'm all contorted yeah I got
well so that's interesting when he said
to actually now so now for eight years I
should keep my hair this way and then
eight years from now go the other way
yeah it's like it's basically like a
a presidency yeah well when I came down
the stairs today with my hair this way
my daughter went like this yeah because
you look like a different guy
something's off and you don't know why
don't I got a haircut yeah I did my hair
hasn't been cut in three weeks let me
ask you a question is it cowlick because
I my whole life I've said cow lick I
don't know why it's called cowlick and
then someone said cowlick and I was like
is it a cowlick I think that it's called
cow lick because the the thought is is
if a cow licked your hair it would stick
up like that
so are you making that up or you think
you've heard that in the past because I
I think that that's what I would say as
well but I don't know if that's true
that's one of those things where
genuinely if you're asking me the truth
I think that I probably made it up so
many years ago that now the LIE has
become the truth okay in my brain but
why cow lick why not anything lick yeah
well any literally a dog like any animal
that has saliva on a tongue yeah if it
licked your hair would stick up that way
100 so let's look this up cow cowlick
lick yeah
okay Pimp's got it
it is a cowlick cow
c-o-w-l-i-c-k it is and it's one word
and is it because of
if a cow licks your hair then your hair
stands up
the most common side of the human
cowlick is the crown that's the back of
the head the Alfalfa that's why for me
to have a cowlick on the side of my head
something's wrong with me the term
cowlick dates is from the late 16th
century physician Richard haydock used
it in his translation of Gian Palo Alto
mazzo good guy the locks or plain feeks
of hair called cowlicks are made turning
upward I mean that's stuck yeah that
wasn't even a good I mean that wasn't
even a fun sentence for any good reason
do you ever think about like people from
the 15th 16th century even earlier than
that literally every grooming issue we
have every bathroom issue we have every
you know uh uh like you know not liking
someone but not I don't know how to go
about like you know walking on eggshells
around a person it all was the same same
exact thing like every emotion we feel
now they felt back then yeah does it
blow your mind yes so it's like in many
ways we're like very connected to that
past where it's like it's just the same
things they were just wearing different
uniforms even them they were evolved as
many years basically if you look at that
on the whole we're at the same time
frame as them right if you look at
everything on the whole they're only a
couple of hundred years ago in the span
of humanity yes so it's almost like
we're like right there with each other
it's just that we're exponentially
growing it's funny you say that they
were I so I think it was Neil deGrasse
Tyson was saying like if you put like
the the all the time from The Big Bang
to now all the time right there's so
many years now if you've had like a
graph yeah we wouldn't even be like a a
a micro like a half of a half of a
centimeter away from like 50 000 from
the dinosaurs like we're in the same
thing I know isn't that wild yes it
gives me an existential dread though
that I don't like what is it
we're coming live we're coming live
coming to you live coming to you live
from my garage
um and in there um is there uh they're
um they're they're uh they're painting
some guys painting so I don't know what
that sound is all right people hey you
got to paint yeah you got to paint
people paint that's the end of that uh
Neil deGrasse Tyson said that Neil
deGrasse Tyson said and I'm butchering
what he said but it was something
mind-blowing of the of the effect of
that literally we are not we're we would
be in the same
um on a graph that he said two things
that literally my balls blown off they
blew off is is is is that fact and then
he also said if you took all the dollar
bills he took the like the width of a
dollar bill and and all Jeff bezos's
money and put it into dollar bills it
would stretch from here to the moon and
back around over seven times that's pure
Insanity which is that doesn't make any
logical sense to me whatsoever but it's
it's baby the facts are the facts if you
want to debate Tyson you can do that but
even though I know you're back I'm not I
can't go through that I kind of just I
don't really credit give him any credit
anymore since he bit Holyfield I don't
think that uh right you know that went
out the window for me with him then yeah
yeah and I was smoking weed on podcasts
yeah it's like how can I really trust
you yeah how can I yeah I make sense
um babe you came to uh my daughter my
one-year-old daughter she got baptized
she was welcomed into the house of
Christ she was literally walking the
house since she's team Catholic now
she's one of the Catholics yeah and um
and we had a great time
at the at the at the venue it was very
nice it was a very nice delightful
afternoon yes we it was awesome it was
nice I haven't been to a function like
that in a while I have to put on shoes
yes you look great by the Doc Martens
you wore yeah I noted it because I
looked down I looked down and I said to
Jazz I said I want to sell shoes no yeah
no stock marks because no no doc
martenses they're comfortable but you
got to break them in their time is oh it
depends on which pair you get what you
are they're already I have five
different ones I have soft broken in
ones I have ones you have to break in
you have to steal toe ones you got the
shiny ones you got the soft broken in
ones you know Doc Martens it's the only
Timeless Timeless and unisex yes if if a
woman was wearing that same exact boot
you had yeah I mean maybe not the same
size but the same style of boot be very
sexy as sexy as you are with the Buddha
thank you so much I was walking out of
the house with a brand new shoe never
worn before brand new sneaker dark blue
but it had white accents and my lady
said that's that's not that's not you
can't wear that not to a christening not
to a christening and I was like but I'm
wearing all black with a sweat sweater
and since she said no but go put on
those other shoes I said all right then
she was right she was right about she
was right yeah well because because she
had and you had all different walks of
life there we had you know I had to be
in a suit it was my daughter we had the
godparents in suits then we had um
people dressing with just you know kind
of Blazers and and things like that then
we had the Casual look with the Doc
Martens and the jeans and that nice look
there were dog jeans they were dark
jeans yes I'm not an animal right uh you
were in a beautiful suit thank you I
believe you wore that student
I've seen you in that suit before No
actually that's the first time I've ever
won that's why you got that suit like uh
man you have you had a nice blue suit
like that as well so that suit I don't I
I don't know where that suit is but the
suit that I was given to me by a friend
I went to high school with Giovanni
bresciani who makes beautiful suits
Giovanni brushiani suits
um and and he so go check his suits out
um and um and so he gave me that suit I
literally great color on you thank you
and you know what I did and and I think
that this is just something something
when you start to get comf in your body
yeah and I'm not fully there yet but I'm
getting close to comp I mine
clip it I didn't I didn't even that suit
you ready for this told him my
Dimensions told him my waist size told
him just in the in the in in what do you
mention what do you mean like you're
three-dimensional no you know hey I'm a
46 oh you measurement 36 ways 32 inseam
okay size 12 shoe 17 neck that's what I
am on ballparking it
never if I if you know when I was a bit
heavier I would have tried that suit on
have to go there a million times because
I I I literally unzip that suit and put
it on for their vet we had to be at the
church at 10 A.M I unzip that suit for
the very first time and put it on at 9
15. did you feel confident it was going
to turn out the way it did or were you
riddled with anxiety that you were
waiting this long to try it on when I
what if well when I unzipped it and I
started to I Jasmine was getting dressed
she said is that the have you tried on
that suit yet I said no and she was like
oh my God she was like what are you
doing could have been disastrous so what
happened was though is I initially put
on the suit and the pants so the pants
fit good I was like the shirt fit good I
was like the pants are the one I put the
suit on the arms were up to here no yeah
I was like oh my God the arm's too short
but it was you know how some of them
have like that little
um not staple but like a little piece of
thread it's somehow the arm like I you
just have to pull something apart by the
by the elbow and then the sleeve dropped
so you had enough sleeve at the end I
had enough sleep well you saw me in the
show would you think that I had too
short of a sleeve no I didn't even
notice that at all yeah I had a short
sleeve I had enough sleep but it felt
good it felt good
um to to be like you know what I just
threw something on yeah not threw
something through something and and I I
felt good about but but here's what
happens yes yes here's what happens is I
felt so good about it and I can't tell
you it's just a human mind I felt so
good in that suit I really didn't I felt
good and I felt you know what because
she's been working hard on on on trying
to get yourself healthy again good so I
felt so good in that suit I was driving
in that suit we were already almost late
for the church I immediately went to the
deli Jasmine was saying we need to go
don't do this I suggest don't talk to me
right now God be walking into my after
my body felt great I got a bacon egg and
cheese and a toasted muffin with butter
and a coffee with extra cream in it and
sugar it was almost like my bro go ahead
my brain said to me you feel good well
here let's ruin it oh immediately oh wow
isn't that crazy yeah but what about
your um your
I was in the fasting window so I could
do that oh okay when I did that and and
so it's not too bad if you're having you
could have whatever you want in that
window and not really yeah
yeah uh you're not supposed to tell what
you did it should not have done Saturday
is my day for sweets I told did I tell
you that Delilah had a talk with me my
seven-year-old daughter had a talk with
me and said I I didn't tell you this I
thought maybe we talked about on hey
babe in the end of December
she said Dad listen you might have she
said I only want you for the entire year
of 2023 only have sweets on Saturday she
said you can have sweets on other days
if I approve it and if you run it by me
she said because Grandpa's got diabetes
and I don't want you to get diabetes she
goes and I won't you be able to see when
you're older she because she thinks
that's all she knows about the
complications yeah because like people
in the family on both sides have
diabetes so she thinks like if you get
diabetes you're blind she's like so I
want you to be able to see on one hand
that is the sweetest most intuitive
honest cute beautiful thing I've ever
heard on the other hand
who the [__] does she think she is
because you're the father you brought
her into this world you paid for her to
live here yeah she shouldn't be leveling
accusations and things and demands that
you like that yeah no I I felt the same
because my initial response was good
this is an indication of the rest of 23
with uh yeah if this is how she's gonna
be if this is how she's going to be she
can find another family when is she when
is she having sweets yeah
yeah oh oh well that's the kicker she
was I swear what about your eyes
she was giving this she was giving this
no keep it the judge yes she
she was telling me this giving laying
down The rules laws of the land for 2023
while eating those Nutella to goes with
the pretzel sticks in the Nutella isn't
it ironic and she had she had a smudge
of peanut butter on her pajamas and and
I was like okay I mean but but who could
play at this game you should have yanked
it right out of my hand and said I'll
see you Domingo though well you know
what happened but but I will say even
though it is tart I mean there are when
you take away sweets during the week
even though I have a goal I gotta try to
do this no no even though like like
right now it's Monday oh well it's
Thursday but we're recording this on
Monday yeah and and and I know now that
I can't have sweets till Saturday I'll
be in Phoenix in Saturday not the house
what's the one I'm doing stand up live
stand up live stand up live in Phoenix
five shows I think they're almost sold
out but christycomedy.com check for
tickies
um so so so I'm
so I know now on Saturday Okay so I've
already actually like I have it in my
head on Saturday I know I can't have
sweets till then so I already know I've
already Googled in Phoenix where I want
to go I'm gonna go yeah I'm gonna go to
this place called um flight this is what
happens and now you're making a thing of
it yes now you're doing your research
because Saturday means something means
something so in effect it's better and I
already know what I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get like these chocolate chip
peanut butter pancakes with whipped
cream they have uh uh um uh muffins I'm
gonna get a muffin I'm gonna do all that
so what I'll do is Saturday is uh but
what I'll do try to do I'll try Saturday
is make Saturday morning wake up after
the shows wake up and try to get the
most intense work that I've had of the
week on Saturday knowing that you you
are gonna [__] eat a thousand
calories at breakfast maybe much more
than that more you're gonna need two
you're gonna eat your daily caloric
limit at breakfast so you Gotta Be You
gotta try to burn at least a thousand
yeah in the gym try and I and I shoot
for that and it's been helpful burn baby
burn chocolate chip pancakes
better work it out yeah burn baby burn
Phoenix is burning Phoenix Phoenix in
January we shall see let me ask you a
question
how much does a shoot like that go for
oh well first of all I want to say
Giovanni brush your own suits have
affordable prices that you anybody can
uh um uh wear could anybody can wear
anybody anybody could wear his prices
anybody could wear his prices but I
would say that suit was maybe 500 500
which isn't you know
a custom suit custom suit he's a good
guy you pick out the color and the
material what is that gabardine
I don't know whoa Merino I I wouldn't
even know where to begin okay I gotta
take you back the color no I asked
Giovanni I asked Giovanni I said
Giovanni brachetta Giovanni prashani
Giovanni bruschetta I asked him I said
can you just get me a knife you know I
need I want two suits and he said got
you and he got me those and he gave me
those those two suits
um and um and uh and yeah and and he
also because he saw them himself I don't
know if you have a person I don't know
if you have a store is it a brick and
mortar
I don't know actually who is this guy
Giovanni I've never seen him in the same
room as Michael Jackson no but I know
but he puts out nice product and he's
one of these kids he's one of these guys
we're the same age he's just one of
those guys that he's been [__] jacked
since we're 14. just jacked just jacked
I remember speaking with the kid that
was lifting weights in sixth grade no he
wasn't even I remember being us being 14
15 years old all trying to like you know
get in shape and stay in shape and he
would be like yeah man I just I just try
to eat healthy and it's something that
don't even work out and I'm like oh yeah
because he's just body is just like you
know the cut chest the cut ABS yeah some
people have that uh right the DNA maybe
for it yeah so so he so so and also
um now what I've done with him is I've
said I think I'm gonna go to his well
I'm actually going to see his Brick and
Mortar tomorrow I think it's in the
story of Queen somewhere I'm gonna go
um there because he said let me I'll fit
you I'll give you like a nice look for
when you wanna like if you're gonna go
do something nice like do it do a
television show or whatever yeah I'll
put you in like he was like something
nice like you know what he said he said
we'll do for you now next you want to
elevate your look you know what we're
going to do for you we're going to do
the suit similar to this different
colors not a shirt and tie we're gonna
go turtleneck up to here turtleneck
that's what we're gonna do with the hair
like this come on come on with the hair
pushed the other way yeah he said you're
gonna you
talk or something like that so we're
gonna walk in yeah or you look like
you'd be like a secret agent at like a
Gala event right I think how do secret
agents in movies by the way beat the
[__] out of everybody and maintain that
flexibility in wing tip shoes with suits
on what did you think they'd have to be
in some type of athleisure I would have
to think that becoming a secret agent
entails putting yourselves in these
situations for countless hours and so
you're so sure of yourself that you feel
you can accomplish anything in a wingtip
and I think that we don't get to see
that part of the movie because it's not
uh necessary to the storyline right and
do you think that you're a CIA agent you
go through all the training yeah you're
doing everything you're you know rolling
over cars you're jumping off roofs
you're beating the [__] out of people
yeah you're passing with flying colors
but you've done it all in a unit in the
army uniform but they say the final test
is do everything you just did with the
Giovanni brush right do you think that's
what they do in the CIA and they and
they give you the wing tips and they say
now get through this tough mudder in a
suit I believe that's probably true yeah
yeah I believe they they they they
probably have to fight in the suit they
probably have to sleep in the suit yeah
probably become one with that suit so
they it's for them they're not even
wearing a suit it's like a second skin
Giovanni's their second skin because I
gotta be honest with you I turned my
ankle immediately in those shoes in my
suit went to shoes I walk I took one
step outside and I thought I got little
things that fall from the trees in front
of my house and I stepped on a little
something called itchy ballsy balls and
I turned my ankle immediately because I
didn't have the support because it was a
low it's a low bottom wingtip shoe so I
don't know how Jason Statham is jumping
off buildings is you comparing yourself
to Jason Statham I shouldn't do that
because he doesn't have it he doesn't
have
first of all you're not trying to become
a secret agent maybe that happened to
him on day one you don't know that well
I am trying to reinvent myself yeah
yeah well I mean maybe that could be it
maybe you could you know do some high
stakes Espionage yeah and you know what
do they get paid and is there a like is
there like a performance review and do
they ask for raises right how do they
like look I found the document like I
found the Declaration of Independence I
slaughtered 85 people yeah all in secret
yeah
I'd like a 10 Race please yeah they're
like they're like they're like so what
do you think you ten percent raised
you're like yeah I killed Bin Laden yeah
like well it doesn't matter it's part of
the job requirements yeah
what that's not true that can't be true
you can't support a family if you're
gonna be away all that time well I don't
think you're allowed a family in that
business wow there's got to be somebody
no go to add hey babe pod right now was
your Dad or Mom ever in the CIA let us
know is the CIA where they train people
to like is that like or is there another
branch that we don't know about that are
like Ops or secret agents like is like
like like like uh what's his name
Tom Cruise mission impossible James Bond
yeah he Daniel Craig is he in the CIA of
the Brit like what is the British
Central MI6 which is yeah is he in that
now what is Scotland Yard
because I was a location
but say am I
say what is Scotland
is that like saying um where's the
Pentagon at Washington Langley Langley
yeah right no the pentagon's in DC
language FBI headquarters headquarters
yeah it's headquarters of like a police
station in London Scotland Yard but I
thought but they always say like oh this
is an agent with Scotland Yard I thought
it was like their FBI but why were they
call it Scotland Yard and it's in London
because they want to keep you guessing
could be yeah they want you to be all
over the place they want Scotland Yard
is happy that this conversation happened
they don't know where the hell we are
yeah if you're listening and watching
and we know that you want a secret
servant special agent gets 150k a year
that's that's a starting Sal
shout out to special agents shout them
out shout out people that are trying to
become shout out all the people
listening that are on the journey to
becoming a certified secret agent we
appreciate you and and and we see you in
the shadows lurking and we feel your
presence and and we like you and I like
that pimp said a secret servant which is
different than the Secret Service I'm
just a secret servant just I don't know
what you just get a tray of eggs
I don't know your bathroom's clean like
that
Bin Laden's dead I stuffed him with
cocktail weenies so yeah
it says it takes two years to become a
secret spy person are you getting that
full pay from the get no I think like
the day you put on the wing tips for the
first time you're getting 150. I don't
think you get paid
okay so let me tell you I do have a
friend
um I haven't seen this guy improve it
prove it I have a friend who's in the
CIA
allegedly because they're always
allegedly but he said to me and I
believe him I I know a good friend
wouldn't lie he went through um he was
first working for U.S customs um and
then he wanted to move on to the CIA so
what they did was is part of the train
had to take all these written courses or
whatever gets to the certain level of
training
then they took him in a van not like
kidnapped on the street but took him in
a van he got to a certain stretch of
highway I think in the Maryland area and
they put a [__] put a blindfold on no
I swear to God because he was not in yet
that's what a blindfold on for about 25
minutes took the blindfold off he was
already inside the facility of where
this CIA place was went through all the
training there or whatever I think he
was there for like five or six weeks
passed gone through and then the last I
heard he was working in the accounting
department of the CIA because he said
that is 95 of the CIA is the accounting
department right that that those spies
and what the Hollywood you know Glory
you know glorifies is such a small
percentage of the CIA it is mostly
literally accounting the CIA is mostly
looking for your taxes yes that's what
they mostly are doing yeah but then are
we glorifying it the secret agents then
that isn't that counter but isn't their
count like terrorism units in there I
think there's units in it but I think
majority of it is accountant so all
right this episode brought to you by
better help we love better help you know
we talk about it I think every episode
we talk about Better Health now and um
they should know that even when they
don't take an add-on that we still talk
about I literally I wake I I sometimes
my day is brought to you by better help
I just literally I'm like today's going
to be brought to you by better help it's
awesome better help it's what I love
about it the most again be um I'm on it
is is I don't have to leave my home to
get a therapy talk to a licensed
professional I don't have I can do it
from the comfort of my own home they
match me up I took the little
questionnaire and they match me up with
who fit best for me and it worked that
that person and I have been together now
for over a year and it's awesome
I love it you don't even have to go on
camera if you don't want to no no I
always say that too it's just like
because I
I started therapy I always wanted to try
therapy but I was intimidated to go find
someone I was intimidated with the price
point yeah if I didn't like it this is
just the easiest way to to get your foot
in the door and try it out if you're
ever thinking about it it's awesome and
right now if you go to betterhelp.com
that's help better
h-e-l-p.com slash hey babe you're going
to get 10 off your first month okay
betterhelp.com hey babe
10 off your first month better hope that
comes here the apple is we love Babel
language learning app you have over 14
languages on there and they make lessons
bite-sized lessons that you can do on
the go yes whether you're trying to
learn a new language connect with an old
relative you're taking a vacation Babel
makes learning language fun yes and what
I love about them the most is they're
not using this artificial intelligence
technology no they're using actual
language learning experts and they have
come together and created this system at
150 language expert experts the teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective with Babel you can choose
from 14 different languages they have
speech recognition technology which
helps to improve your pronunciation and
access ten minute lessons and they're
they're saying that you could start
having a conversation in a language
within three weeks ten minute lessons 10
minute meals it's amazing right now get
up to 55 off your subscription when you
go to babble.com hey babe that's
babble.com hey babe 55 off your
subscription Babble language for life
when is it that the FBI and the CIA
cross paths and they were like this is
our [__] case like stay all [__]
this is my case now it's FBI no it's CIA
yeah they argue about it how does it
when is it the FBI or when is it the CIA
I I honestly I don't know because in the
movies though the FBI will always come
in and be like this is a crime after
local law enforcement they'll be like
I'll take that yeah we're in charge now
yeah yeah but then I feel like the CIA
could do that too who supersedes who so
it's saying FBI's domestic cias
International
okay so the F because because that's a
big
like law enforcement there's a lot of
times the law enforcement like oh I
can't if you could just make it to New
Jersey you you know NYPD can't chase you
and the CIA there where the FBI
sometimes they're chasing someone and
then it's like do not let them get out
of the United States borders then they
got to just turn the plane around right
right they got a bank left because
they're like oh the guy made it to
International Water that's right CIA
will keep it going yeah we'll keep that
[__] going
he went through all that training like
months and months and months of training
and they sat down and they're like
it's not gonna work
[Laughter]
I like a trained assassin in the wing
tips you think your first mission like
you're gonna go to like somewhere and
like info like a kill like a
presidential candidate with like a gun
and they just sit down I'm like are you
familiar with QuickBooks
that's what you do yeah Turbo Tax
Windows Emmy was a real [__] let's see
what you can do with it
weird fact what do you think the maximum
age to become a spy is oh so 27. oh so
you say you're saying okay your question
is once you hit this age there's a last
year you could train to become a spine
it says Case by case they might wave
okay if you're this age or above oh so
you can so in other words the cuddle you
cannot be any older than what to be a
CIA agent okay I guess 27 it's wrong but
I put it I locked it in it's funny that
we don't have a presidential limit of
age I know you know we don't I mean if
you need it for that I mean they have it
in China in China I don't think you're
allowed to be a president over I think
you have to be at least 55 and you can
only be 55 to 65 but the new president
whatever who does your suits yeah yes
exactly so that's an interesting
connection yes and um and he uh but he
changed the law but I think I think that
you normally in China you have to be at
least 55 to 65. whereas I think you have
to be 40. oh you have to be at least 40.
I think you have to be 40. oh
there's probably years of training 27
that was a stupid guess I feel like it's
a little young I feel like I feel like
maybe 35. 35 is the cutoff well it
depends because because you got it you
got it are you in the CIA no
[Laughter]
just a lucky guess I guess good Jokers
oh my God yeah
yes I guess
[Laughter]
35 that is a good guess but it also is
it makes sense so I was like it's like
when when I think a UFC fighter starts
going downhill I don't know most
athletes start going down if you're if
you're if you're killing it after 35
that's pretty good and I'll tell you
I'll tell you one more time I probably
said it before I'll say it again I am
now older than every single professional
athlete in sports including Tom Brady
including I'm older than Tom Brady wow
he was born in 77 I was born in 76. WoW
football 1776 baseball
1666. wow plus 10 years yes football
baseball hockey
basketball there's not one person older
than me not one they used to be like
Adam Vinatieri what might as a little
bit a little older yeah something like
that but like I don't I don't think so
man by the way did you see the Cowboys
kicker miss four extra points yeah five
right five and then the one guy blocked
and then on Sunday yeah against the
Niners it got blocked and then they said
it would have missed yeah it was gonna
miss you if you watch it first of all I
was watching those games live he missed
one didn't think anything of it people
missed chip shots once in a while second
one I'm like that's interesting I bet
you something's wrong with his foot pull
his high winds right then there wasn't
then he hit it then they let him go back
out he missed the third one yeah I said
something's going on here I wonder
what's going on here because they're not
saying anything yeah they're just going
oh you missed another one yeah and then
he came out for a force and I was like
if he misses this one yeah and they
don't address this what the [__] he
missed the fourth one bad I'm texting
with my friend but people and I'm like
is he it's too obvious to be throwing
the game right right he I mean he missed
four I said ever happened ever no only
time in playoff history and I think
there was one more maybe I know it was
four yeah and then he finally hit one at
the end at the end of the other game the
the the game of last week the game one
last week he fought he the very last one
he hit that one against the box he hit
that one the last one so but then but
then the first one where all eyes on him
of when they were playing the Niners it
got blocked but he was going to miss it
he was going to miss it supposedly
because I was like okay but if he gets
blocked
uh and the kicker the the they said if
you get a block it's so close that you
like you know if you block a field goal
from far away way something with like
the angles of the kickers it's easier to
block those but if you're blocking an
extra point if it's the kicker's fault
you were gonna [__] shank that thing
so bad and the guy was just able to get
his hand really but I but could you
imagine the pressure on no do you think
he was shaking I I know for a fact
thing about the whole game I mean if
you're him and you're on that kind of a
stage in the playoffs I mean if his team
was not up by four touchdowns is that
what it was yeah right it was like it
ended up being 24 nothing when he missed
the fourth one right if they were if
that was a game I don't know they would
have been death threat remember Scott
Norwood yes he got in on the bills when
he's when he missed the field goals of
the Giants won the Super Bowl I think it
was 1990 yeah he got death threats for
years after that right yeah and I think
they made a movie about it do you think
any chance in hell they retain him the
Cowboys or you think he is cut like you
can imagine I gotta I gotta look at what
his stat line he was really good at
Stats yeah I mean dude I would you
because once once you get in your own
head you start having an internal
meltdown right if I was him and they
don't have any other kid I don't think
he could make any moves to pick up
another no there's not many of them
right I mean I guess if you got hurt
they'd have to oh no because you're
saying on a playoff roster you can't
even bring anyone in well there must be
something because who's going to kick
the ball if he gets hurt right right but
it might be someone that they have to
pull up from like a I don't even know
where yeah I was watching yesterday I
was watching some football coverage
analysis and Jimmy Johnson the old
cowboy I love him yeah yeah he said and
I've heard this before but I thought it
was really funny they said he had The
Yips yep
he's only gonna have The Yips and the
guys had The Yips since last week the
guy's got The Yips yeah The Yips is I
want you guys to go out there this week
and use I got The Yips in a second yeah
yeah yeah send it to us we just we just
shot a bit for Jokers last week and uh
we were in a waiting room and uh and we
made the lights go off in the waiting
room Murray was in there right we made
the lights go off and we told Margaret
to tell the guy he was waiting with that
Murray was the receptionist he's like oh
these lights are sound activated they go
off every like minute or two right for
uh for energy saving right and to get
them back on you just have to go yep
this is before I heard about The Yips
yeah so he tells the guy that and
Murray's working and every every one or
two minutes the lights go off and his
older black gentleman's and he goes
yep and then we turn him back on
Let It Go off again then Murray leaves
the room the guy's all alone we did it
like five times the guy's alone in the
dark in the room going yep you were
dying right oh my God I was dying now it
says here the punter with the most
missed kicks over a career is 304 missed
kicks in 27 Seasons what
304 missed kicks in 27 Seasons how could
he stay on the roster a 27th season
what's his name George blanata b-l-a-n-d
the guy who does your suits yes
it's got the president in China and a
field goal kicker first of all that's in
2017 that's for the NFL his first season
was 49 1949. oh okay so this is back in
the day when they were yeah who knows I
mean they all uh they were they were
like that I think that the field goal I
think that kicking extra points was much
further away and I I think that that's I
I imagine a guy
field goals in the 40s was still kicking
field goals the year I was born
that's crazy how old you are guys
[__] kicking Fields how old was he uh
when he passed let me let me see
I mean well if he played 27 that's 304
which means he missed
it's like 11 a year
that's a lot of terrible percentage and
he stuck around that long well I mean
dude like because they make field goal
kicking look easy in the NFL but it is
so insanely difficult to do that yeah I
mean and when you see somebody who
misses all those in a row like that
you're like oh my God the professional
athletes just make [__] look he died in
2010 but he's old school looking
he pushes his hair away from his cowlick
which is interesting he knows what he's
doing yes wow that's crazy what's the
longest field goal record that's the
field record in the NFL do you know I
think it's like 60 60 something 60
something yards I think that the Vikings
when they lost when they beat the Giants
um in the regular season of this season
they kicked the one of I think that was
the longest field goal in NFL history it
wanted to win the game against the
Giants I don't know don't quote I know
some sports are Sports Nuts fans 66 yard
was the longest both Ravens when
let me see it doesn't say the year oh
the Ravens it was probably the remember
that um
uh uh remember there was a kicker on the
Falcons who like up until like a few
years ago he only had like the one bar
on that like everyone else yeah yeah
what was his name um Anderson maybe he
just had like one bar on the Falcons
you're not taking a Jamal Anderson are
you no no I think um 2021 on the 66 yard
for the Ravens yeah so it was Justin
Tucker yeah we're just okay oh my God
that was wow 66 yards it's insane that's
crazy I wonder by how much he made it I
wonder if it like made it like you know
what I mean yeah because because the
thing is like with just like you know
athletes and you know all the training
and everything like that like it will
somebody will hit a 70-yard field goal
like that's gonna happen you think so
and it might start to become like the
norm that would be crazy you get a touch
back into 20 you go one first down and
kick a field Club then they had to
shrink the pull goal posts like you have
to yeah that's that's the most missed
kicks in one game is seven field goal
attempts almost the same guy guys four
NFL teams two Conference Championship
games and only a few more shots to win
big on the playoffs with DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL counting down to
Super Bowl 57 new customers can bet just
five dollars and get two hundred and
free bets instantly are you not a new
customer you can feel the conference
Championship Thrills with stepped up
same game parlay love stepped up
take your shot at an even bigger NFL
payout and boost your winnings with each
leg you add up to 100 percent right now
all you got to do is download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app and use code
hey babe hey babe new customers can bet
five dollars on the conference
championships and get 200 in free bets
instantly only at draftking sports book
with code
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply okay
and I just want to say this this weekend
I think the hottest game of the week I'm
looking forward to the Bengals and the
Chiefs me too Bengals Chiefs are big
well here I like Bengals cheeks but I
think even hotter Eagles Niners really
I'm just gonna put I'm gonna bet on all
of them you're gonna bet on all of them
I'm gonna go on DraftKings and have
myself a field day and I'm gonna put in
that code hey babe all right the same
kicker missed seven field goals
I thought you meant that like like Maher
or Tucker not the same guy also he
missed seven in one game
do you think too like at that you're cut
you got to be cut at that point yeah
like like how did you get there I wonder
if there's everybody Zips like he's got
The Yips if there was a situation where
like you know you've missed at the fifth
field goal you miss where the coach just
flat out says to you if you miss this
field goal take off your pants and go to
the locker room you're done like if you
missed your pads your pants your pants
and your pants take off your uniform and
could you imagine like he missed it he
just starts jogging towards the locker
he's like I know
yeah
someone did that last week there was
like an interception of something and
they just ran into the locker rooms
it was like the announcement was like
that doesn't make any sense
the celebration
even two other guys ran into the tunnel
and into the locker rooms they're like
you should have got into the game
penalty but he didn't yeah
dude he kept going
yeah yeah last weekend wow there's also
a guy who never missed a single attempt
his whole career who Stephen gotkowski A
guy who did your suit
yeah
this guy's all over that was the guy
from um right
oh yeah yeah um no what um no they were
Stephen Adam Vinatieri was the big one
and then no remember they were polish
guy wasn't he on the Cults too or
something with Peyton Manning he was
like
I was still Vinatieri always I think so
yeah no but Vinatieri had a whole career
with the Patriots and the Colts didn't
he play for both vegetarian with the
colts for a long time no only the Colts
and he was the one who hit all those
field goals in the snow Yeah at one
point he was like the man I know that
but remember there was a Polish guy
pimps right there was a Polish guy who
was awesome who everybody wanted it
might have been gostowski I forgot his I
don't know yeah gostowski Steve got
Steve kowumpki's
who's that this is him what's his name
Steve oh ostrowski you know
what team does he play for
this lineup yeah he was there he was
sorry he was the guy with Brady wasn't
he I thought yeah I thought like I don't
know
um do you have a kick one I've never
even attempted to kick a field goal
should we do that have you ever tried
serious I'd love to watch that have you
ever tried
oh my God you should just go to like the
high school over here and just we'll get
it and we'll see who we will do but do
you remember they had to I think they
made this illegal do you remember there
was one kicker I forgot his name but
remember he it was like in the 90s took
a show off no no his shoe he like cut an
indexes
yeah it was like sick and they were like
you can't do that he basically put like
a hammer in the front of his shield
how far you think you can kick it can
you throw a ball 66 a baseball 66 yards
I mean maybe on a few bounces it would
get there but in the air
200 feet isn't it
more three three feet in one yard yeah
oh wait but a baseball you can throw a
baseball 66 yards I don't know I mean no
I don't think I don't know I don't think
so I think honestly
180 feet 66 yards is what about on 200
feet hold on I'm gonna tell you 198 feet
right yeah yeah I think that I think
that I genuinely could throw a football
may maybe 15 yards
no it's I'm telling you it's hard have
you ever seen you could do more than
have you ever stood on an NFL football
team have you ever stood on it yeah yes
dude it is it's it's it's it's
otherworldly you never realize how big
the [__] thing is you ever think
about like a short quarterback like Doug
Flutie was like five six how did he see
the receivers no these guys are good was
he just [__] close his eyes and just
like [__] it do you know how long it
would take me to run 100 yards probably
like 40 minutes I was gonna say you'd
have to do it I think in two or three
sections yeah like we'd have yeah and
sprinting okay ready you are what yard
line do you have to be on to get to the
end zone before getting tackled by
someone that is chasing you from the NFL
like and someone fast like like a
legitimate NFL linebacker yeah yeah
or like yeah or like a safety or you
know where are they starting from well
what do they need that's what I'm saying
like how much of a headset do you from
End Zone End Zone they're starting at
one end zone you got to get to the other
end zone what what yard line do you have
to start on you're running full speed
that they're not going to catch you so
if I think if I if if you put me I think
if you put me at the at the 50 yard line
50 right you put me they're in the end
so you put me at the 50. yeah I think by
the skin of my teeth like you know like
when they almost yeah I think I could
get there Diamond what about you so yeah
I was gonna say at least 50 but if you
think 50 then mine's probably like 30.
but because but they but the truth is
remember that show Pros versus Joe's no
you don't what no Google Pros versus you
don't know the show I don't think so oh
my God you're a [__] [__] are they
fine athletes to go up against people
named Joe no no yes exactly Pros versus
Joe's they take a regular guy some of
them were athletes uh former athletes
some of them weren't just guys and they
would have them go up against like Joey
Porter the linebacker from the Steelers
and the Dolphins right and then they
would have uh try to get a rebound off
Dennis Rodman um try to hit a fastball
off Dennis Eckersley and the football
players they would get they would
[__] demolish these stuff Pros versus
Joe's right TV 2006. Spike TV remember
because remember do you remember how
great Spike TV was they were they were
they uh they offered to buy a show from
us actually we sorry we might say I sold
them a show well despite the original
True TV no no network that falls yeah we
our first story we ever sold was the
Spike TV we shot a pilot with Spike was
it Pros versus Joe's no it was like a
single camera sitcom oh really yeah they
were gonna they were interesting they
were thinking about doing that yeah yes
well Spike TV if that was if you don't
guys don't remember the young people
that network was specifically they
outright said it this is for men there
was like the manscaped of Channel it was
like yeah it was like we don't you know
everyone's trying to go after women and
the women's sports they were like we
don't care about the dudes yeah they
were like this is for men
shortest quarterback in NFL history Doug
Flutie five five I'm not seeing Flutie
says Eddie LeBaron five seven the little
general
oh [__] what year he's already little
enough you got to call him a little
general let me see what you're doing
five seven I mean I'm only five nine
five ten I'm five no ten five ten five
ten I but but but think about I mean you
know for an athlete five seven this
guy's at a six Six coming at him that
are 350 [__] 20 times it's
interesting like more guys don't get
like literally like there's not someone
getting carted off the field weekly okay
this is what I was thinking about
starting last week I I I I can't get out
of my head no matter who you are
how do you deal with when they when
there's 15 guys on you want to pile on
yeah and it takes like one minute for
everybody to get up so you're at the
bottom this this not just 15 guys it's
15 guys between two and four hundred
pounds right and they're on you and you
just got slammed down and they're
jumping on you right and little by
little you know when someone's under
there fighting for the ball they're
trying to get everybody off and it takes
and everyone's taking a sweet time how
do you train for that what are the guys
at the bottom doing and are they talking
down there well they probably are like
they're probably [__] trash talking
to you well let me tell you oh we've
I've we've had the honor of having uh
Tiki Barber NFL yes he told right into
the Duck Sauce he told me that in here's
a dirty little secret when they're
fighting for the for the ball like the
fumble and everyone dies people are
[__] biting chewing biting grabbing
their nuts they're trying to grab your
he said how many times one team has the
ball and somebody will just go in there
and [__] twist and pull or try to
just really just do anything they're
trying to get your dick to make you give
off that phone he really said they'll
hit him they will and he said the amount
of [__] talking is insane at the goal
line at the on the offensive line like
it is insane he said guys some guys
purposely will not shower that whole
week they want to smell like full open
ass so guys just want to get away from
them like it's all tactics he said
another thing
he said you got to understand like a
professional athlete he said like
there's time for like he will have a bad
game simply because like he got into a
fight with his wife or he has to [__] or
like they're just humans right playing
so he was like that's like a lot of
times I think of them as superhuman but
no he's like you know they'll say oh we
don't know what got into you know the
quarterback today it's like yes his
girlfriend left him and he had diarrhea
right that's what happened right we go
on stage
but he said they grab and twist their
nuts constantly honestly if you get to
that level of professionalism and you're
not good enough to just you know do
something without stinking on purpose
yeah you probably like if you need the
help of not showering right it should
probably reassess yeah people go that's
right that's messed up you want to hear
one of the most disgusting things you've
ever heard in your entire life like
truly like kind of don't but like if
this doesn't make you dry heave I don't
know if you're human okay so we had
Wayne kerbet on the podcast once New
York Jets Legend whatever yes yes a
great guy walk on from hospital great
guy Wayne Quebec you were there right
when we interviewed Wayne correct in the
back that was on the Chrissy chaos
patreon last year he told us I said
what's some of the craziest hazing
things you ever had to do he goes the
craziest thing I ever had I ever saw is
one one year they made the rookies he
says this was like you know you could
never do this now but this was early 90s
because one year they made the rookies
all the offensive linemen shaved the
calluses off the bottom of their feet
and put it in a Ziploc bag over the
course of a year and then on the last
day they made the rookies sprinkle it on
like a caesar salad and eat the salad
foreign
could you imagine
I would you no no wouldn't you would
just say don't give a flying [__]
if you can't if you don't see my
Integrity my work ethic and I'm not a
good partner to you and I haven't had
your back or whatever that go [__] off
right I just I don't need to do that I'm
an adult that got here on my own you
think I'm gonna eat your foot shavings
on my Caesar salad I'm not I'm not what
are you gonna do what is anyone gonna do
tell tell are you gonna tell the staff
no yeah the coach would be like yeah
don't do that yeah yeah he did that
supposedly the guys did it because it's
like a camaraderie that the guys have
that they were like they just wanted to
do it a nice had a camaraderie I have no
idea that's insane or like do you ever
hear the stories of like the best
quarterbacks like this you know because
the offensive line is like you know in
football like obviously what protects
the quarterback like Brady had the best
he would just buy them cars like he
would just buy them gifts and be like
not on the most important part of a
football team yes or no offensive line
yes I believe it is yes with a good
offensive line it opens up your offense
no matter who you have anyone just
slightly capable in there they're gonna
be able to run through a hole right and
they're gonna and and if you had that
good of an online you're gonna have time
in the pocket I think that they say
defense wins games I'll say offensive
line probably more so than almost
anything yeah yeah and and Kicking
kicking's huge yeah you have to have an
accurate kicker well you see you see now
like when people like oh kickers aren't
you know they're gives a [__] about
could you would you mind
got rid of kicking would you mind if
there was no kicking in football for
real no kicking in football nope yeah
yeah
the kicking is the only part that deals
with the foot it's interesting right
they've named the whole sport after a
very very small part of the game yeah
very interesting so they did they're
like Scotland Yard they're trying to
throw us off that's what it is have you
seen you know what happened you know why
they probably didn't uh get rid of
mayhar after the four five misses he
might he might be a secret agent he
could be undercover yeah he's got to
stay there and he's got The Yips and
he's messing up now big that's what it
is or the the cat the team likes them
because they're like listen this guy ate
all our calluses on a seasonality he's
done he's done it multiple years he's
one of us he's proved himself yeah and
and we can't we can't cut him today he
just ate a bowl of our shavings right
before game time yeah we can it
literally if you even attempted to do
that today just the act of it just
putting your calluses in a plastic bag
you will be brought up on an HR
violation immediately immediately
immediately you cannot do that would you
ever remember that was
I would never
remember and I know it's like bad
whatever but like do you remember do you
ever hear that story of like it came out
only a few years ago with Peyton Manning
when he was in college about how he used
to like oh just open up his [__] and
like fart on the masseuse and like he
was like the whole team would be dying
laughing or whatever and then like you
know like 20 years later the woman was
like I'm suing you
and and supposedly like I think I might
have heard that somebody farted on
something somebody said like I forgot it
was like somebody who knew him like in
public was like yeah you like when he
got that news he was like with like his
friends and family and they were dying
laughing even though he's getting they
were done they're like you remember
crazy ass Becky like because he used to
just fart like like literally like Shard
on her at the University of Tennessee
and like he was and like they still use
it did you make up the part where we
opened up his ass
no I think it was like he would Payton
you know Mr Manning opened up his
buttocks like you know flatulated on the
you know it pops up right uh something
else pops up for Peyton yeah yeah he
thrusts his crotch in her face when
she's massaging his foot Oh I thought it
was farting unfortunately not always I
see I see how you can mix the two up ah
yes okay no but somebody did do that
there was an athlete somebody used to
farting on people I'm telling you no
that wasn't maybe okay so I mix up the
stories it's not okay
you have a fun fact fun fact about the
little general oh yeah let's know the
shortest quarterback in the NFL was also
a veteran of the Korean War interesting
the Korean war was a tough one a lot of
players veterans is that a thing or no
well you know back in the time when the
US was fighting all the wars I mean you
know Ted Williams all these guys they
would fight they were they would go you
get drafted yeah I know George Williams
got drafted right Ted Williams got
drafted and had had such amazing stats
for the but still I think three years of
that he was fighting in World War II his
head's on ice isn't it Ted Williams head
is on us I think Walt Disney's head is
on Ice yeah
San Antonio Brown repeatedly farted in a
of man's face and I thought it was too I
thought it I thought it was I was like
[__] Antonio Brown's wild I mean do
you see snapchatted pictures of like his
wife his ex-wife and he's like somebody
hacked my Snapchat they were like no
they didn't what do you think the guy's
asking for for getting farted in the
face I have I have what he's demanding
what what the man oh that's not settled
yet
well at this point uh he asked for that
uh so that that lawsuit is still
lingering
like it I don't know very nice I'm just
trying new things I like it uh I think
he's well it's Antonio Brown is he is he
brown or the Steelers organizational
both he's doing
in his face
you're a juror and you guys are in the
back and like coming and you're like all
right how much would you give for one
for okay now multiply that by five how
much would you give for five right and
like people are eating their lunch and
like we gotta we gotta wrap this up
right
um I think he's asking for five million
dollars what is uh seven and a half
million twelve thousand dollars that's
it
are you blowing smoke up my ass no no
twelve thousand dollars no and it's
still going on what is he in what is he
getting paid to be in the CIA
where did he get where did he get that
number is there a guide like a manual
like how did you come up who came up
with twelve thousand dollars it was like
it was six fonts I want two grand theft
right and then and why is it still going
I take it that's clogging up our [__]
Court System 12 grand for a fart in the
face no 12 grand for far in the face is
but a jury has to come together to
deliberate that it's gonna cost him more
in legal fees yeah if I'm Antonio Brown
I pay that immediately speaking of 12
000 I'm going to open up
Sal's card South uh card from my
daughter's baptism which he came let's
see what it is oh this is nice
congratulations on your christening love
you lots next stop communion oh [__]
yeah
no no question this number that you get
which by the way is very generous I
appreciate it baby thank you this it
goes to the captain love you too I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna tell Violet
you know we got some money tell her we
took care of him tell her took care of
him but
everybody
you know the people who gave checks all
gave
not as much as that but in that ballpark
is there something that and some of them
was like the exact like I got 10 checks
from people that was the exact amount
which was a random-ish number but it was
the exact amount do you think people
Googled the venue it was at and said how
much a plate there no way in the world
it's can't no no one's doing I know how
do you I don't understand how you're not
gonna find that catering menu and then
understand what you're paying and
official you can make an assumption
about about that no but it was a like
you gave you gave a number that was like
a more round number like I'm talking
about everybody gave an odd number and
it was like 10 different people that
didn't know each other yeah so I'm like
where did they get something that ends
with a seven five or something yeah no
no no no it was like 400 and I was like
where it where is that like where is the
400 coming from I could see that I could
see because I could see I could see any
number of an even hundred
but 10 people get get that exact one
well I don't know maybe with two people
like a couple hundred each at this day
and age I don't know yeah that's true
you know all right it was just
interesting I didn't know if maybe
people Google
you know Google like uh you know I've
never done because it's very difficult
to try when you go to any type of
wedding baptism any event how much do
you give yeah I didn't know I didn't
know myself I just Googled it's 50 bucks
they're saying on here 50 bucks a person
or a christening gift if you're not the
god parent you give 50 bucks but that
might be just without a party at a
catered home yeah right I mean right
because that's you know but see here's
the thing too is is when you got to
think about things in the National level
right like we're gonna get [__] our
rates are higher here right you go so
you go to other cities other states and
sometimes people will you know like like
the way of like it's almost like when
you live in New York it's almost like
you'd live in a different country like
weddings are insane because it costs so
much more to live here though so in
reality uh the 50 bucks you're giving
the same percentage of your general
income and life expenses as we are we
just have to pay for more [__] right
right that's all it is that's the
difference but it's like that everywhere
because even even if you go to a wedding
and like you have to go to a wedding in
the in the middle no no anywhere outside
in New York Pennsylvania whatever it is
they just do weddings like I think that
they they have it right and we are we we
are a little bit we are over yeah no
we're living we're putting um we're
putting too much pressure on ourselves
it should just be a gathering yes with
good food and drink with friends and and
that is what it is I like to say good
food enjoy drinking out drinks you say
drink and I like that you do that often
I always catch you always say we're
gonna have food and drink at the house
not drinks which it's interesting is
that is that incorrect no I think more
correct and I think that it's more
formal okay and I like it okay yeah yeah
I like that I like that about you we do
we talk Super Bowl yet oh yeah you well
we're gonna yes we're gonna Super Bowl's
gonna be in a couple of weeks which
could patch my homes very well you know
very well might make it and what do you
think is going to be in the Super Bowl
honestly the way that the Bengals are
playing though I think it's going to be
Eagles and Bengals but I'd like to see
Niners Bengals
yeah you you don't think the Niners are
going to beat the Eagles I don't the
eagles look so I mean they on a giant
they they would die they beat the [__]
out of the Giants where it was literally
like actually I was getting sad here's
here's here's here's how bad I was
watching the Eagles it was not a fun
game I was watching the Eagles beat the
[__] out of the Giants so hard that in
an effort to make myself feel better and
get happiness I put on the Casey Anthony
documentary
something a little lighter something a
little lighter yeah that's what I did I
went to a peacock and I put I said this
is actually making me feel nicer which
by the way by the way and I'm gonna tell
you
with proof that I know for a fact Casey
Anthony did kill her baby and I'm going
to tell you that this has been hey babe
wow
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe
[Music]